we've been spending the last month
putting a whole bunch of new 14 and
16-inch macbook pros through various
tests and comparisons and have also been
using my own personal 16-inch m1 max
model at my house basically every day
and unfortunately we've noticed quite a
few problems over this past month so in
this video i'm not only going to cover
those problems but i'm also going to
provide solutions for the ones that
actually have them or may have them soon
but don't get me wrong i absolutely love
my new 16 inch macbook pro for various
reasons and to be completely honest it's
the best apple device purchase i've made
in years but nevertheless there are some
problems that i want to be fully
transparent about because they are very
real and some of them have some
interesting fixes that you seriously
need to know about so let's get right
into problem number one one of the
things that was the most excited about
with these new macbook pros is the new
120hz promotion feature since i do a lot
of web browsing at home and i love how
smooth it is on my iphone 13 pro max but
to this day both safari and chrome are
still limited to 60 hertz scrolling
which is very unfortunate on these new
macbook pros now recently apple released
a new version of their safari technology
preview which claims that it supports
120 hertz scroll animations but everyone
on the internet says that it still
doesn't work so hopefully apple is going
to be working on a software fix soon
because they did intentionally show off
safari 120 hertz scrolling in their own
keynote video so they have to add it
soon now getting into the second problem
i recently upgraded my internet at my
house with centurylink fiber which now
supports speeds up to 940 gigabits per
second both up and down and while
testing the wired ethernet lan speeds
using a qnap gigabit ethernet adapter i
got very close to the full speeds which
was very impressive however when i
tested out the wi-fi it seemed to always
be slower than on my iphone 13 pro no
matter the location within my home up to
a difference of around 200 megabits per
second in certain spots which is a bit
disappointing since i need the faster
speeds on my macbook not on my iphone
and upon doing some research i found out
that the new macbook pros actually have
slightly slower wi-fi speeds compared to
older macbooks as you can see the
maximum phi data rate for ax wi-fi six
is actually a hundred megabits per
second slower than the ac wi-fi five
data rate on older max but making it
worse the wi-fi five speeds are
significantly slower at 866 megabits per
second compared to 1300 on older macs so
if you're still using a wi-fi 5 router
you'll likely see a downgrade in terms
of wi-fi speeds until you upgrade to a
new wi-fi 6 model moving on to the third
problem it's got to do with the new
notch now while i've personally gotten
used to it and i honestly don't mind the
look at all especially since it gives us
the super immersive display with thin
bezels there are a couple of issues that
you might experience thanks to the notch
first of all i've noticed that in some
games like rocket league that have
important ui elements in the top center
of the screen the notch can actually dig
in and cover important info at times and
other than that there are actually some
apps that have many menu bar items that
will be hidden underneath the notch like
quinn from snazzy labs showed us in a
recent tweet and finally if you have a
lot of menu bar items on the right side
like we do when we run our tests and
comparisons like for example to show cpu
temperature and fan speed some of them
will actually disappear if they get too
close to the notch which is very
annoying but in my daily use i haven't
really noticed it myself since i don't
really need to do any of that at home
but it is something that you could
potentially run into yourself for
problem number four i want to mention
that even after a year of the original
m1 max being out in the wild we still
have a lot of software and apps that
don't have full native apple silicon
support in terms of video editing using
final cut pro we've had to replace some
of our motion vfx plugins with ones that
may have missing features because they
just aren't supported anymore now of
course i know this is fully up to the
developers but it's already been a year
and a half since apple announced the
transition and this kind of stuff can
really slow down these new insanely fast
macbook pros for example the open source
blender rendering program still doesn't
support metal which makes rendering much
slower than it is on windows laptops
with traditional graphics cards that use
cuda or whatever else and then of course
there are issues with unsupported audio
plugins in logic pro so it sucks to see
that the transition still has a lot more
work before it's fully polished for
problem number five this is perhaps the
most annoying thing that i've
experienced at home and that's actually
display blooming as we all know the new
14 and 16 inch macbook pros come with
new mini led displays that can get
insanely bright while also having
incredibly dark levels of contrast
however since i don't personally have a
tv in my home i resort to using my
macbook pro to watch movies which is
great because of the new and improved
speakers but if the display isn't
pointed directly at you then the
blooming becomes noticeable and it's
actually quite distracting and the thing
i didn't expect was that i would notice
the blooming in shots that are more
dimly lit and hazy like many of the
shots from the movie dune and it just
gets so much worse when you're viewing
it from the side and especially if your
eyes are looking down at the display
which may happen when you're sitting
upright on your couch to maybe eat
snacks or grab a drink or whatever else
so with that said i actually have to be
intentional about how i place my macbook
pro when watching something to avoid
blooming which is a bit disappointing
but the display still looks so much
better than the previous ones so it's
still worth it for problem number six
we've been noticing that the viewing
angles in general aren't as good as they
were before causing the display to look
a bit dimmer from the side and the top
this is likely due to the switch to the
new mini led display tech since it has
more layers that are required to make it
look great with all of the local dimming
zones and everything else which also
makes it look a tad bit more cool toned
compared to before but once again when
you're looking straight at it there are
no issues at all and most people likely
won't even notice when looking from the
side for problem number seven we've been
suffering from that new memory leak
issue that has been messing with the
performance of the new macbook pros
especially when editing off of a nas
storage system causing a bunch of lag
and other issues so to quickly explain
this problem the ram that usually gets
cleared and swapped by your apps just
stops getting cleared and it keeps
filling up starving the rest of the
system and slowing down performance as
you can see in this clip which shows
windows server using up a massive 33
gigabytes of ram on my imac pro but
thankfully some users are reporting that
the latest beta version of macos
monterey has fixed this problem but of
course not everyone has access to the
beta or wants to upgrade to it so
hopefully the public release gets this
fixed soon now moving on to problem
number eight the 14 inch m1 max macbook
pro actually throttles the performance
quite a bit compared to the 16 inch
model which apple didn't mention
anything about in their keno for example
the gpu clock speed on the 14 inch will
not go higher than around 11 36
megahertz no matter what even if the
temperatures are cool and you're plugged
into power it's literally a hard cap by
apple since we weren't able to get more
than 35 watts of power flowing to the 14
inch m1 max's gpu compared to as high as
43 watts on the 16 inch model which can
get up to around the full
megahertz clock speed which is around 14
higher than on the 14 inch which of
course leads to faster performance
across the board as you can see in the
gfx bench graphics test and based on all
of the other tests that we ran the
biggest performance difference we saw
was when we tested cinebench and 3dmark
wildlife at the same time and the
16-inch ended up being 37 faster which
is a huge jump but don't get me wrong
the 14 inch is still more than powerful
enough for almost everyone and is by far
the fastest laptop in its size and
weight class which is why max recently
returned his 16-inch and stuck to the
14-inch for the awesome portability so
definitely check out his video on that
if you haven't already for problem
number nine this finally brings us into
gaming support i've already created two
gaming reviews using both the m1 pro and
m1 max macbook pros and they gave us
very impressive performance at least for
the games that actually worked games
with mac os ports ran very well like
diablo 3 starcraft 2 dota 2 and
minecraft but some games just didn't
perform that well like cs go but the
worst part is that bootcamp support is
now gone so you have to resort to using
apps like parallel 17 and crossover 21
to play windows games and while they in
fact do an excellent job there is still
so much translation going on that it
greatly slows down their performance
compared to playing native games for
example we had to turn the settings way
down to get grand theft auto 5 to run at
60fps on the m1 max macbook pro which
keep in mind is a very expensive machine
but playing world of warcraft which is
native was amazing easily getting over
with the settings turned way up and
matthew moniz even showed that it was
almost as fast as a 3080 mobile gpu
laptop which i don't think anybody was
expecting but the issue is that there
are barely any native games and even
with crossover 21 direct x12 windows
games aren't supported yet so you're
pretty much limited to older aaa game
titles but the worst part of all is that
games that use kernel-based anti-cheat
won't run at all so you simply can't
play any online games like call of duty
vanguard and we're not even sure how
long it's gonna take before they finally
can but thankfully there is a chance we
could get boot camp support in the
future since qualcomm had a secret
exclusivity deal with windows on arm
which might be why boot camp support
disappeared and since we know nvidia is
working on an arm-based gaming laptop we
should hopefully get anti-cheat support
for armed ships in the future and
finally for problem number 10 while the
microphone quality has definitely
improved compared to older macbooks it
sometimes sounds a bit dull or muted
when you have some background noise in
the room so it almost seems like it's
over compensating for the noise
therefore cutting out the high end of
the vocal range compared to older
macbooks so just hear it for yourself
and now let's compare the webcams i have
both opened up right here and i'm gonna
switch between them as far as the video
and the audio so you guys can compare
which one looks better and which one
sounds better now there is a chance that
this is a bug that can be fixed in the
future but it's definitely a bit odd to
hear right now but don't worry this is a
very minimal issue and it's unlikely to
bother a lot of people since the quality
is already so much better than basically
any other windows laptop microphone
system out there so with all that said
those are the problems that we've
noticed over the past month which is
actually quite impressive since it could
be a lot worse and keep in mind that a
lot of these have to do with software so
they can get fixed with updates and
they'll get fixed over time when we get
better apple silicon support which is
very reassuring but if you've been
noticing any of those issues for
yourself go ahead and comment your
thoughts down below and be sure to click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]